Lilette entre ciel et terre l'auteur et
l'illustratrice Huguette Payet l'éditeur
Orphie
il était très grand comme un ogre les
villageois petit il avait une très
longue barbe argentée et les yeux pleins
de douceur et de vie
un bon ordre en quelque sorte le bon
ogre des hauts comme on le surnommait
sur la nuque une longue queue de cheval
comme celle des filles et au pied des
tongs grandes comme des battoirs
Ivan tel était son prénom d'origine
n'avait pas d'âge et quand il parlait il
avait un air tout autre que celui des
villageois dans la parodie
à mon étrange assurément pensèrent dans
leur langue les habitants méfiants en le
voyant arriver au village
coup ça lui vient faire ici
promenons-nous dans les bois de l'île
est pendille qui va retrouver la vie
l'homme le raconta alors qu'il était né
à l'autre bout du monde dans un pays de
prairie et de brume qu'il avait parcouru
la terre car il les met d'un amour fou
qui ne parlait pas très bien le français
mais on le comprenait il prétendait
qu'avec du courage des outils très
simples des moyens naturels et des bras
il était capable de sauver des terres en
grand danger
c'est la Providence qui t'envoie ici dit
Antoine le doyen du village qui depuis
des années avait dû quitter les Terres
de son illette tant elles étaient
maigres et
usées
suis-moi je te montrerai les lettres
pandiées entre ciel et terre battu par
les cyclones délavés par les pluies
ravagées par l'ignorance des hommes
il marche cher pas moins d'une heure
sans entendre aucun chant d'oiseau avec
leur Bertel chargé de pioche de picaroc
et de l'Arpont sur le dos quand
Ivan se mit à imiter un chant d'oiseau
seul un couple de Tweety se rapprocha de
lui en chantant tout l'environnement est
malade ici conclut-il j'ose espérer que
je n'arrive pas trop tard ajouta-t-il un
qui est
je me fais vieux
Ivan repris en toi mais je te promets un
coup de main de temps en temps cet
illette habitait jadis par mes ancêtres
mérite de sortir de l'oubli et de
renaître j'ai confiance en toi je me
réserve le secret de ta récompense la
nuit venant les deux hommes se
séparèrent
Ivan s'installa dans un abri de fortune
et a même le sol sur un lit de feuilles
de bringélier il s'endormit la tête
pleine de rêve de liberté comme les
anciens du temps du marronnage autour de
lui les montagnes magiques aux formes
d'animaux et d'humains montaient la
garde
allongé sur l'un des sommets la sorcière
call aux orteils écartées ne dormez que
d'un œil
Ivan n'était pas seul
d'un geste bienveillant le ciel tendit
alors sur le calbanon d'Ivan sa grande
moustiquaire étoilée pour sa première
nuit à l'illette
il aurait le lendemain tout le temps
nécessaire pour faire l'état des lieux
et jugé s'il pourrait vivre et
travailler ici dans la paix qu'il
recherchait
au loin le cri d'un dernier Fouquet
remplit la nuit
promenons-nous dans les bois de l'île à
te pendille qui va retrouver la vie
chaque jour
Ivan se lever et se coucher avec le
soleil chaque jour il travaillait sans
relâche il est lagué les arbres pour
faire des ombrières naturelles aux
plantes médicinales par des couches
alternées de feuilles et de branchages
retenus par des bordures de Pierre il
reconstituer la terre et l'empêcher
d'être emporté il replantait les espèces
endémiques et aussi diverses plantes à
rhizomes comme les longues aux feuilles
vernisées pour retenir la terre quel
programme la famille d'Antoine avait de
l'amitié pour Ivan qui de plus cet effet
d'autres amis au village tous venaient
spontanément à l'Ile pour aider Ivan à
la soigner de ses plaies d'érosion de
sécheresse et d'abandon
une petite source timide se remit à
chanter il va la fille serpenter
habilement sur la terre cultivée sans
engrais chimique
attendre cresson irré apparu et des a
remis maculer sortir de terre par
centaines il va aller les vendre à la
grande ville de la côte qu'il observait
par temps clair depuis la grotte aux
hirondelles on les appelle encore ici sa
langue
et puis un jour il fallut se rendre à
l'évidence Cécile la dernière fille
d'Antoine et
Ivan le bon ocre des hauts se regardait
avec des yeux de plus en plus brillant
il va n'était si courageux si volontaire
et Cécile aimer avant tout ce qui
faisait sur la terre de ses ancêtres
chaque fois qu'elle accompagnait son
père à lillette Cécile apprenait à Yvan
la langue de son pays et le nom de
chacune des plantes dont son grand-père
lui avait appris tous les secrets elle
transmis leur secret à Ivan qui vécutiva
sous les ombrières naturelles pour en
extraire des huiles essentielles des
arômes précieux et en faire des tisanes
bienfaisantes
en les voyant tous deux arpenter les
lettres de bout en bout allant même
jusqu'à piler le verre des bouteilles
pour cimenter les fissures des rochers
avec la même ardeur Antoine pensa je
sens que j'aurais bientôt la grand joie
de marier ces deux-là ils sont en
harmonie
et Antoine pensait juste quelques mois
plus tard en effet on vit les villageois
tels des fourmis laborieuses portées sur
leur tête de grandes feuilles de tôle
des marteaux et des clous pour achever
la case tout en bois qui se montait au
fil des jours pour les futurs mariés en
bois de l'illette bien sûr telle était
la surprise qu'Antoine avait promise à
son arrivée à Ivan ne se doutant pas un
seul instant que sa propre fille la
partagerait aussi
gageons que des voix d'enfants au double
accent se mêlent à cette heure au
concert de milliers d'oiseaux dans les
lettres ressuscité cachées entre terre
et ciel quelque part au cœur de l'île
volcanique pour le bonheur de tous
promenons-nous dans les bois de
l'illette pandiées qui va retrouver la
vie
souhaitons que les nombreuses Ilettes
disséminées dans les montagnes de l'île
et pour certaines encore abandonnés
deviennent par la magie de quelques
amoureux de la terre des lieux
authentiques de vie